back to the Samsung stage it's day three
or is it day four of you three just
having this conversation I guess it's
day three of the press conferences but
day for if you sorry day three of the
live stage and everything open but they
four if you include the press
conferences so we're gonna go with three
joining go three alright cool i'm a day
if I didn't Dave good thanks Dave's here
a show a brand new game that I've never
seen before but I've heard about it and
so tell me what are you showing off
stated so I'm showing road not taken
which is coming to the ps4 betta pc and
mac okay it's basically basically a
puzzle roguelike so for the people who
played Triple Town and don't starve it's
kind of like the two of those combined
um same studio you guys who made triple
time then yes right okay well done
that's right fantastic and so you're a
ranger plays you play as a ranger
investor rescue kids who are lost in the
forest okay for a noble sir fashion
that's yes absolutely the force is
procedurally generated there are dozens
of objects and creatures that can appear
in the forest so no playthrough is ever
the same it's a fairly hard game it is a
roguelike so when you die you're
basically starting over okay and I'm i
guess i'll just go ahead and show you
let's have a look we've got a live demo
that's fantastic so I why don't why
don't we just play you taught me through
tell me what's going on that'd be great
serious so here's the Ranger and as you
can see he only has one basic ability
which is he can oops I can open the
options name oh my god i can press space
to pick up something and i can press
space to throw it like that's what I do
all right um the I can also speak in the
options menu I can also teleport to the
mayor any time those are might those are
my two abilities teleport to the mayor
so what's his role just reloading cake
see you there and it's like Sasha do you
want to get is he wants he pays me when
I bring the kids all i see so he's like
you saved the kids you give him to him
he's like well done and hughes that's
right all right it was kind of a jerk
though here's we really care but I
realize you're kind of trafficking
children in this game oh actually they
basically sends the kids out to collect
berries that's why they're lost in the
woods in the first place Wow he says
he's awful he's a total jerk he's a jerk
yo charger I don't like him okay so here
you go so I have you'll notice there's a
door and the far side it has a six next
to a nice camp so I have to get six ice
cubes to get
there to open that door ok it's only
four in this room I gotta go get some so
ok I'll go in here here's to bring one
over oh you'll notice that when I hit
that ice cube and turn that thing into a
giant block just one of the random
things that can happen also that that's
useless to us cuz it's no longer a nice
yeah now I can't move it now it's just
stuck there I can't even pick it up it's
gonna be walking my way so I kind of a
pain in the butt yeah there's four let's
go get this last guy over here come on
and come up and I'm about to die i am
going to cheat so that i don't that
doesn't matter i'm playing completely
inefficiently right now oh the lesson
there guys if you can cheat cheap that's
what they say that's pretty much and the
uh oh actually and before i even open
that door let me show you some of the
cool objects oh this little raccoon yeah
a little guy doesn't cause any problems
if you toss him then you make him mad
and not on what and what and their work
you know now he's attacking me the wolf
the wolf is totally peaceful in fact
he's a little bit scared of me yeah but
if i make the mistakes cornering him
then he'll start attacking me know god
damn raccoon ok rain in the acid a yes
yes he is too early Christian anagen I
need to get these 6v6 ah I swap places
with anything you're misteri almost
there almost there there we go doors
open okay great now there we go okay so
where's your health cuz you can handle
all their my hopes up here in said 386
lat cheated they did not die reine see
Patrice Evra all right yeah but every
time I oh that's an important thing
every time I pick up something and move
with it not a ghost yep that's it goes
okay you'll notice that every time I
move while I'm getting this I lose
energy so that's the major thing you
need to be efficient need to throw
things not carry them around right so is
your health the same as energy side yeah
I help is the same thing as my energy
the mushroom by lady because it sorry I
just I just love you I'll pop of it so I
keep your decinse you did this yourself
it's pretty great so in this room
because it's night it's bright and sunny
I don't lose energy when I walk around
with things so this is actually kind of
this is a nice kind of like quiet
peaceful room um let me show you a
little bit of the crafting that you can
do this game because it's not just about
rearranging objects ah that raccoon is
just killing me it's not just about
crafting objects it's about moving
around objects tell us about crafting
things so for example there's a magical
so I am
deer out of the way there's a magical
stone well if I hit a red ghost with it
it turns into a magic potion of course
yeah I know exactly it's totally
intuitive right that magic potion will
make things afraid of me so oh koo i'll
give you an example so i'll use it this
is totally useless but i'll use you to
make this white block afraid of me now
that white clock will run away from me
if it can all right yeah so I see now
we'll work on anything so if I owned an
epic stone it'll work on the big stone
try to make the book center like it'll
work on the raccoon so the raccoon will
start protecting me yeah there's a bunch
of other things you can do there's like
lots of objects taking crap from the
game so i'll also for example make that
potion and that motion is a potion of
gripping and that motion makes anything
easy to pick up even if i normally
normally not able to pick it up rightly
so but there's lots of other things that
you might want to use it on I can make
axes like to make Spears I can make food
I can make all kinds of stuff in this
game not just with the stone well but
with like a lot of different ingredients
so how big these levels I mean you
bleeping to like three different screens
I mean I have any children are there
they need to say when in each typical s
mission there's four but it ranges from
like four to eight and the force can be
anywhere from quat you know four five
rooms to like 12 rooms it just depends
with difficulty permission right now I
mean you'll see that it says here seven
down there in the bottom left corner
yeah there's up to 15 each year mission
represents one year there's 15 years in
total if you make it to your 15 which
most people want because it's really
hard you'll die of old age that's that's
your reward for finishing the game he
died all the people town come together
to mourn your fury mourn your funeral
he'll come after day and that's right
that's what cared about you um so yeah
so in here I haven't actually rescued
any kids yet so I'm just goofing around
let me go see an oh ok this is an
example of a custom room this is not
procedurally generated we've littered
the game with about three dozen things
that we've handcrafted to be kind of
interesting puzzles alright so this is
an example of one of those interesting
puzzles it's full of these these crows
that teleport stuff when they hit them
and all of these [ __ ] the Hawks are
actually kind of bastards if you walk
gonna meet the talk he does five damage
and teleports you oh wow and he just
teleported to be into a blizzard room
that's not good don't your energy gonna
go down in here like I need to play or i
can do yet so i can well if I really
need to if I'm really screwed i can try
to teleport back to the mayor right
that's kind of like your failsafe um but
in this case I actually kind of want to
show you what happens in this room I've
got friendly foxes who attacked ghosts
on my behalf yeah so they're kind of
cool we like them but let me show you a
boss encounter actually however at it I
will oh I clicked the wrong went on take
two more seconds you'll get the scene of
the puzzle room load custom room okay
there we go so now this is Baba Yaga
she's well this is actually a folk
legend that we borrowed it i think it's
russian or polish book legend but oh
yeah basically she's a witch she likes
to eat kids so when you come into this
room the first thing that happens is the
door slams behind you and you have to
figure out how to open it meanwhile
she's taking a kid's a kid's toy and
feeding it to her cauldron which is kind
of a warning hey the kids might be yeah
and if you don't rescue the kids in this
game you fail so like that's one way of
dying rescue the kids so that's actually
a really bad thing it's also feels
terrible when watching all the topical
so in this this mission I happen to know
because of course I worked on it Oh is
she chasing after you as well no she
totally ignores me she couldn't care
less about me she's all about feeding
the kids to the cauldron so I need to
get these skulls together make a
skeleton key get the skeleton key into
the door great doors blocked now I need
to get to her before she puts all those
kids right there possibly the cauldron
so she can't get em kids I didn't handle
that once you well no but they did they
both died there just okay to not two
kids there was she got the other kid
when I wasn't even paying attention
apparently I'm he selling my own cake so
there's a bunch of encounters like that
that show up but most the content like
ninety-five percent its procedure
generated it's more lines at the stuff I
was showing you earlier cool I'm so show
us some other some other levels ads
we've seemed like Boston Karen every
seem like an early game I want to see
you actually save a child cuz so far
you've not saved any children I don't
sorry nice landscape any children yeah I
don't think we should do that made me
feel better all right they'll sit better
with me I'll send myself to an earlier
maybe I'm a pic an easy level
I'm actually pretty good doing good at
the game I have been it twice oh yeah
okay it only takes about seven hours oh
wow if you're good at the game it'll
take my seven hours if you're bad at the
game it will take 25 hours probably like
when you first started tastic yeah so
I'll go through that was the village by
the way that I walk through there
villagers in the town that you can level
up your relationship Rob really so that
Mary's not kind of like you're you're
gonna base yeah we return to every after
every mission you come back there you
give them stuff they give you stuff they
can get but it's not just so it's not
just owe income friends then we become
lovers then we become you know spouse's
you actually bad things can happen just
like in real life so if you were
leveling up to relationships with two
different people and you get them both
to a high level one might get jealous or
the other and break up with you one of
them could get sick and then you have to
bring the medicine or they die so
there's actually any valuable life
lessons in there I think it that the
valuable the Lester the game is actually
trying to send it's simply that there's
no such thing as a perfect life you just
have to deal with the curveballs that
life throws at you so that's alright
that's something that happens in town
like a your little character goes to
sleep in fight you so who is your
character exactly i haven't heard of it
i'm really at all characters and we
don't tell you much about him he's a
mysterious Ranger when he first heard
the game it shows you that he liked dies
in the in the forest and then he wakes
up next to this staff and you're like
picks it up and it glows to life and
that's all you know about him that like
he's this dude found this staff and now
has this magical power and the people in
the town are like oh hey you're a ranger
because they recognize this stuff you
should help us out a healing okay yeah
it's pretty much that simple there's
more to it but I don't want to do give
any sports right that's fine don't worry
all right there we go there's a there's
two what's the pizzle what's a puzzle
here right you got those am three and a
Hawks those are Hawks I wanna go let's
go for me yeah yeah what I want to do is
get that kid reunited with her mom just
throw these ghosts anyway get a mama
United one of five children are scan
this is the lovely roses the easy
mission sure they appeared right next to
each other and there wasn't that much to
do what is the mole dude in the bottom
what small will actually swap places for
those things okay yeah so as you will
you pick up the game for the first time
like I is there a method of teaching you
what everything does or they like
introduce to you the different
characters and you have two best guys
have the man yep just learn as you go I
got yes you're like oh that's what he
does go right and you can get tips like
so for example if you bump into the
thing it says it's slippery hunk of ice
so that doesn't tell you a whole heck of
a lot but you can actually go into your
book of secrets mmm nice it tells you
there I swapped the stuff with another
object think so that's that's fairly
straightforward sometimes it isn't that
it doesn't tell you quite that much like
and you just kind of have to figure it
out and also tells you like recipe for
crafting there as well that's right so
I'll give you an example the UH bring it
up real quick oh I went too far uh where
is the indented stone oh I didn't bump
into it so it's not showing up in here
well anyway there be high I told you
three bee hives when they combine turn
into honey and then honey is something
in a few Walker but you get energy from
so fast there's tons of stuff like this
in the game and actually if you'll
notice the it says there's I've got 25
secrets out of 200 in the game so there
are tons of stuff in the game that
people haven't seen on you know in this
demo yet excellent so I'm what about a
kind of level crafting so if I buy this
game and I you know I place I might
actually beat the single player which I
probably wouldn't cuz I kind of suck at
these games but I try I probably like
there for 50 hours say it did that and I
want to make my own levels is that a
thing you guys are gonna include yeah we
totally want to do that so the good news
is the tools that we the designers use
to make content for this game yeah are
really really simple and really powerful
I can make new like a really cool new
object that does something interesting
and unique in like a matter of hours so
we want to take those tools and we want
to make them accessible to players as
well so not just that they make levels
they can actually make a whole new
original objects let's do interesting
new things and I think I don't know who
get it out we certainly won't get it out
at lunch we're hoping maybe by the first
or second update to get those tools at
the people so that they can make their
own fuzzies fantastic well we've still
got a few minutes left so why don't you
boot up like one more example to show us
should meantime though if you're
watching home and you got some questions
for Dave the best thing to do would be
to tweet at me at cam fraz Rob there it
is the lower third appears our
production guys are super sleek they
knew that was coming so if you tweeted
me with any questions for Dave I'll
throw them at him he'll knocked my the
park bay at Dave one more one more
scenario what you gonna show us i'm
going to show you another boss room this
is a guess the spider boss room and
you'll notice by the boss room Yeah
right and you'll notice there's a theme
in this game which is that bosses tend
to not care about you they tend to go
after the kids so which is really
stressful because obviously it's not no
one wants to see kids die and of course
if they die you actually failed our
mission so I love that should be on your
business cards no
one wants to see kids that's right this
quote of the day so in this aim here's I
remember this is the turn-based game
every time I move two steps the spiders
move one step ah right so you'll notice
they've surrounded that kid and they
started cocooning her if I don't get her
out of there by eight turns actually
batuque it with two spiders around her
it's for turns they will eat her the way
I can unwrap her is by tossing her away
and that upsets the counter oh I had to
somehow get these kids out of this room
before the spiders eat the kids and this
three spiders and one things right oh
and hold on I cheated i teleported into
this room so the doors aren't up area
now the doors are open now I can get her
out so there's a oh that's unfortunate I
think we ought here we go so one thing
you can do I'm just going to toss that
spider right out of the room and
probably make it a little fake spider
yes ok now I need to get this kid out
the spider is blocking the door that is
not important convenient I am ok let me
get him out of oh and there's there we
go ok spiders out of the way ah bone
okay that didn't work out yeah one down
two guys games hard yes so here's an
example of I've got her over here now
I'll do a little bit of strategy
teleports in the mayor ok come around
from the side and grabber notch and I've
saved I've gotten one of three away from
the so that's an example of another boss
encounter where it's all about being
smart if you simply just bumble around
in the center of the room eventually
you're gonna find that all the kids have
been eating so what you really want to
do is think strategically about can I
come in from the side can I toss in some
objects to help me maybe I could have
grabbed the parent from another room
toss her in here and made a match ok um
maybe I could have made a fear potion
and hit the little spiders with it so
they would run away yeah listen there's
lots of different lost different ways
you can take okay um well I think he's
so that like one minute left so show us
one more one more in character ok ok for
dinner I'll show you something it's not
about some counter i'll show you cool
puzzle room
ah checking room how's that oh this is
not the room that I was expecting okay
let's do this one yes so these rocks yah
bump other things when you move them
around great happy rugs yes they're
happy looking rocks and they show of
other things around me I need to get
these three three of these little jelly
looking things together there's just one
trick with them when you toss them a
distance oh these rocks are really going
to make this hard um when you toss them
you'll notice it just change into a
different object right and now I don't
have the conical thing that I need to
actually open the door so i need to
actually figure out how to keep it tight
of crap you have to craft a conical
thing though you've still got three I
just need it right toss there you go I
keep resetting it and it's so it's some
direction I toss it in there heyo so if
you toss it left it turns back into the
conical thing so somehow i have to get
three of these conical things together
camping that when I toss them down
they're going to change into something
else that I don't actually want wow
that's the puzzle in this room and if I
can get three together that door will
open it I can keep going well Dave it's
being absolute pleasure having you on
stage this morning thank you so much for
so much for showing us world not taken
so I mean if people have likely seen
they want to know more they want to
eventually get the game when it comes
out when's it gonna come out what
platforms can they play it on so it's
going to be this summer I got a pc mac
ps4 and we're hoping to do feet as well
at launch but it's not a couple months
after lunch fantastic okay great well
guys Dave thank you so much joining us a
stage don't go any recognized it is of
course the final day of e3 which is bit
sad but we put so many great games
coming up all across both are stages
today we're gonna have elite dangerous
on this stage pretty soon which is
something I'm very excited about so make
sure you don't go anywhere we back in
just a couple of minutes